le cyclisme féminin se développe
s'intéresse de plus en plus de monde
[Musique]
c'est vraiment super moment je pense que
les audiences ont été très bonnes aussi
donc il y a pas de raison que ça
s'arrête je pense que voilà ça va aller
quand progressant aussi beaucoup de
public c'est vrai que je m'attendais pas
à ce qu'il y en ait autant sur le sur le
bord des routes on sait que le cyclisme
féminin se développe s'intéresse de plus
en plus de monde parce qu'on va retenir
je pense que voilà ça intéresse les gens
et tant mieux et nous sur le sur le vélo
c'est ouais ça nous pousse quoi j'ai
beaucoup apprécié d'avoir beaucoup de
monde sur le bord des routes et ça ça
nous a donné de la force je pense on
voit aussi que les gens aiment aussi
nous regarder donc ça fait plaisir super
premier édition on a vu pas mal de
choses beaucoup de choses différentes et
surtout ce qui m'impressionne c'est
c'est la ferveur quoi le public c'est
vraiment c'est la première fois que je
vois ça sur une course de se dire même
avant le départ du Tour il passait les
petites interview à la télé et de se
voir passer à la télé c'est quand même
pas rien et puis voilà je me suis pas vu
la télé parce que j'étais en train de
souffrir sur le vélo mais je pense que
on m'a vu quand même quelques fois et
c'est vrai que ça fait aussi
[Musique]
je pense qu'il y a peut-être plus de
sponsors qui vont arriver plus d'équipe
aussi plus de moyens et peut-être aussi
plus de nouvelles courses qui vont se
faire c'est que le début mais déjà si on
a chaque année c'est déjà bien c'est
beaucoup de fierté voilà d'avoir milité
pour le retour du Tour de France féminin
et d'être là aujourd'hui j'ai envie de
revenir l'an prochain oui
[Musique]